but when i when i got my my uh my jab i
was
extremely tired of the day off and i
couldn't do anything because i decided i
was going to watch a tv show
it was an animation not quite an anime
all over technically an anime
technically in japan
[Music]
is it good oh my god it's amazing it's
really good it's [ __ ] amazing
so good i'm like there must be a reason
why this show's
getting memed a lot it's really good i
was really blown away by how
just incredible it was like cut to title
screen right now
not invincible oh yeah incredible sorry
i'm sorry what are
yeah it's great i mean [ __ ] man it's so
good i just i want season two can you
can you sell it on to me like
what's it about i know it's about
superheroes
it's kind of hard to sell it without
spoiling it because there's a massive
spoiler in the very first episode right
it's one of those things that it is
literally the best show to experience
knowing nothing okay okay because i
almost think i think that
me seeing some of the memes spoiled a
bit for me oh yeah
yeah because i imagine those those
twists would have been so much
more impressive if i didn't know they
were coming yeah i knew they were coming
because i saw the memes
but if anyone i'm not going to talk too
much about it i will just say that it is
probably one of the best tv shows i've
watched in
like the past year yeah that is really
[ __ ] okay
yeah how many episodes is it it's only
10. eight episodes and they're 45
minutes long
oh okay okay and it's it's just amazing
like
it's everything is fine did you watch
the boys i did not it's very similar
it's very similar to the boys
which is funny that they're both like
amazon prime exclusives
but uh if you didn't watch the boys
that's fine you just
it's a i'd say a more brutal take on the
superhero genre
i heard the boys is like super [ __ ]
gory right oh yeah yeah yeah
i'd say like that voice is more like
humory yeah a lot more humor involved
yeah invincible is just like pretty
brutal yeah it's it's invincible is less
of like a
like a parody or like a subversion of
the superhero genre and more of just
like
i i don't know how to like describe it
without spoiling major plot points so
like like a deconstruction maybe i
wouldn't say it was a deconstruct it's
just like you know
if realistically if superheroes are just
randomly like powers that were given out
some people are going to be [ __ ]
okay okay
that's what happens here but it's it's
just again i don't want to talk about it
much other than
it is amazing i've watched it anyone
watching this if you've been you've been
thinking about it
100 i've definitely been thinking about
that and the boys
yeah you should watch both because i
like with watching invincible it was the
first time
i remember after i finished the season
or finished the series it was the first
time
i had like an episode just really
shocked me
because like you know we watch a lot of
anime we read a lot of media and so it's
been the first time in a long time where
something's just
shocked me in that way because i just
it's something that i just hadn't seen
before okay so that's why i think
it's really worth watching and watch it
before everyone starts jumping on this
trend and everyone starts like
trying to [ __ ] rip them off or
something or do their own take on it it
was a it was a comic book
if i'm not mistaken yeah it was a comic
before and like from what i've heard and
i've been told like we haven't really
had too many like
comic book adaptations outside of the
very safe
family-friendly marvel owned ones yeah
what i've been told and
what my friends tell me like there's so
many good stories
in the comic books that have not been
touched yeah so many mature ones as well
and i'm hoping that this will lead to
more adaptations of really [ __ ]
mature comics because
i feel the last time we got like a
mature comic adaptation that i thought
was pretty
good or like it wasn't good but it was
really entertaining was sin city
i never watched that yeah the movie yeah
it was originally based off a comic
was it yeah i like watchmen the movie
i like that yeah i like that movie
i like how you just like uh really
whisper that i like i like watches i
feel like people don't
even watch men well i watch man watch
man
a watchman suspect a gadget yeah
no because i i heard the same thing
about sin city as well because like a
lot of people like no it was crap you
know it was like i was over the top
you know all that kind of stuff but i'm
like isn't it supposed to be over the
top
i'm sure there's a bunch of comic book
aficionados in the comment section that
will tell us actually there's these
amazing adaptations
yeah yeah yeah yeah because i heard that
watchmen was just really hated by
everyone who read the comics and i
watched it and i was like i thought it
was a good movie i have no idea about
the source material
same thing with uh v for vendetta as
well that was over
yeah i [ __ ] loved that movie and
apparently comic book readers hated it i
don't know why maybe they have a
legitimate reason i feel
i feel that's the same with like
anything i know it could be [ __ ]
tokyo manga readers right it's literally
just
all mongering it's being like oh no it
wasn't that good the manga was way
better
literally the comic book was way better
as an anime fan i know how it is
as a manga reader i know how it is